how are you doing today sir i'm i'm
doing great i just want to say i really
enjoy your videos um you interviewed my
friend david lowry recently and uh oh
yeah and the youtube algorithm keeps
showing on the main page of youtube your
videos now keep showing up for me and
i'm really enjoying them so
so it's a pleasure to talk to you right
hopefully hopefully by the end of this
you're not like [ __ ] this guy
oh great we could we could swear in this
one that's great you know something i
used to swear a lot more and i try not
to because um i try not to
sometimes when i get excited about
things that just comes out i will try
that's exactly i'll try not to as well
but it's a real pleasure to meet you i'm
i'm saying it's a real pleasure to talk
with you today about your movie um but
before we get into your film i am
curious if you could have done a season
two or beyond if everything sucks and i
know you've gotten this question but
yeah what
did you have ideas for season two and
beyond oh yeah
yeah
yeah we spent a lot
ben york jones the co-creator of the
show and i spent
uh spent like two months basically
figuring it out figuring out a lot of it
and uh
yep
yep but what exists what exists we get
to join the ranks of you know something
like freaks and geeks that you know
lasted for one season and
it warms my heart when people bring it
up because you know the experience of
making that film is still like one of
the greatest experiences of my life
yeah i i'm curious because especially
the
it ended in a way that i'm like oh i
wonder what's going to happen next
yep
yep oh yeah we all felt the same way but
i won't push you on that so i can tell
you one thing if you want to know a
little nugget there's one little thing
that we've we've talked about which is
that so this is a television show about
a girl named kate um who uh is is coming
to terms with her own sexuality and uh
and she never actually gets to come out
to any to her family during the show
and her mother has passed away and we
always had this idea for a scene where
the first person she was going to come
out to was her mother that she was going
to bring emmeline who was played by
sydney sweeney in our film they were
going to go to this graveyard have a
picnic and she was going to tell her
mother that she was gay and so that's
the scene that i always wish i could
have filmed
that
yeah i would have liked to have seen
that
um
uh if you could get the financing for
any project what would you make and why
okay i really so
so i'm gonna have to dip my toe into the
water of this film in order to come
circle back to this let's do it so
so
so this film was inspired by erotic
thrillers right you've got and when you
say that word that or that phrase it's
two words when you say that it it
conjures different things like you might
think of
the sort of sweaty neo-noirs like um
like body heat or wild things right you
also have the blank from hell movies
like the hand that rocks the cradle um
or you know single white female the
roommate from hell um but our film we
describe it as as a um
as a
a steamy moral dilemma movie in the vein
of unfaithful or indecent proposal
that's what this film is
and if i had unlimited money i would
love to make
uh basically the next evolution of what
this film is crossed with a blank from
hell movie i have this idea for a blank
from hell movie that i think would be
really fun to make but it's very big in
scale
that well i think that means that a lot
of people need to click on and watch
this film uh to you know
let's hope the word of mouth spreads
yeah
yeah um it's interesting so you you
bring up erotic thrillers for me as
someone who watches a lot of movies and
pays attention to hollywood i feel like
you can get away with murdering someone
in the most violent way possible in a
movie and everyone accepts it but if
you're gonna show
two different types of people kissing or
nudity or
sex
hollywood like the mpaa just throws up
the the warning signals and says no
what the hell has happened in the last
like you know how why is this the way it
is oh dude you're preaching to the choir
i i don't i
i don't know i mean i think um
you know for us it was just
you know for us i
it's tricky because i think
i want to give you a really good answer
to this the
for this film i felt like it was
important you know because this film is
it's about voyeurism and it's about
seeing something that you're not
supposed to see
and like like you just said like cinema
is
traditionally very chaste
so the image of a naked body in this
context is disrupting
um
but i think that these movies are
oftentimes incredibly
sexy because you have the chase you have
the you have the all of the four the the
90 minutes of foreplay leading up to it
where you see the character yearning and
you see their desires so that when it
when the event happens it's
it's it's it's even more intense um
and so i felt justified in doing that
with this particular film
um and i think
as for why it doesn't exist i think not
a lot of not a lot of writers are
approaching their screenplays
thinking about using sex as story um and
that's what i wanted to do here where
you know character is being moved
forward or there's like actual plot plot
is happening as as as the sex is
unfolding and there's tension when
there's sex unfolding um
and normally because normally when you
do see it it
yeah it is quite chaste but also you
could more often than not remove it from
the movie and the story would still
exist you know totally have you found
that since making this movie or since
writing this movie that you are much
more cognizant about closing window
shades and looking and just being more
aware of things
yeah well i think it's more it's more uh
for me like the whole thing is actually
an allegory for instagram right because
i think you know like the literal shades
like no one's looking i mean
who knows where this movie's gonna lead
but
i'm sure of it
but i think you know for me i think it's
like this this theme of like the grass
is always greener right which in the
last 10 years has gotten worse because
we all have this app called instagram
where at any moment we can peer into the
windows of the lives of strangers and
you know even though even though we're
seeing has been filtered and is
presenting a partial view into that
reality
uh and it may not even be real it still
makes us feel
uh dissatisfied by comparison right and
so um it's crazy like we know this is
bad for us
instead of us our brains saying don't
look
we've become addicted and so
that sort of feeling in that sense is
what i wanted to capture with this film
um
but through using this sort of rear
window milieu as our sort of allegorical
frame
under which we can explore that
sure i still think though people um oh
anyway that's a whole separate thing
about blinds and
right
living in a city um i love talking about
the editing process because it's
ultimately where it all comes together
um so and i asked this of every director
but did you have a much longer first cut
did you have a lot of deleted scenes
no we had to no not at all i think
there's like one deleted scene um we
we had to be very specific with how we
shot this movie because um
so
so we built these two apartments on a
stage um on the biggest sound stage we
could find and they're based on a
practical location that's in montreal so
anytime you're peering down into the
courtyard that's that's a real that's a
real location anytime the characters are
entering and exiting their buildings
that's a real location and we had to
sort of marry
that with the two
uh sets that we built right
and so in order to do that i had to be
very specific with how we shot the movie
because otherwise um yeah and so i
didn't i didn't give myself a lot of
options honestly and i knew that when
they were looking like that back and
forth
i didn't i wasn't gonna get like i
wanted to stay in the people who are
watching i wanted to stay in their
perspective so i never got coverage that
they couldn't see i never got an angle
that they couldn't see it was only them
and their pov shot
and so um
so yeah the editing process
the thing that was the hardest was just
trying to make things feel a little bit
shorter and to tighten the screws here
and there when we could
but it fundamentally did not change
from
the very first cut that we tested to the
cut that we have now
i added a scene i got some insert shots
but aside from that it's just a slightly
tighter version of that
one of the things that i really enjoy
about a movie is when i don't see the
third act coming and your movie has
definitely some twists and turns i don't
think the audience will expect
were those things always in the
beginning of the script can you sort of
talk about like you know what i mean
like it's pretty i wrote this script
backwards so i knew what i wanted the
ending to be and literally and that was
where i sort of started from um in fact
the actual the initial seed of the idea
came from i visited a friend who had
just moved to downtown l.a and um
and
i was browsing around his his loft and
looked out his window
uh
and saw across the way these this couple
that were just wandering around their
apartment completely naked and and my
friend he was like he was like oh are
they naked again they do this we just
all sort of co-exist here
he even had he tried to pass me a pair
of binoculars that he had bought from a
pawn shop this is true
and you know you want to look you know
you shouldn't and sort of that was kind
of the light bulb moment of being able
to figure out like oh sexy rear window
there's a movie here somewhere and i
stored it away
and then
trying to when i was unpacking what that
could be
i i the ending was the first thing that
came to me and so literally every single
thing that came before it was
constructed was took a very long time to
figure out how to carefully construct it
in a way for that ending for that ending
to really to really land
yeah i'm very curious what people you
know because it's like i really want to
talk specifically but i want to ruin it
for the people that are you know um my
last thing for you um you obviously
in three weeks if you want to do this
again and like we have like a spoiler
episode i'm like so down and yeah
i definitely
yes um okay but i also want to because i
love talking about the the specifics of
endings because i think people always
like to know like once you've seen
something you want to know more do you
know what i mean yeah um but my last
thing for you you obviously get to work
with an incon in
intimacy coordinator i wanted to make
sure i announced that right what is it
sort of for people that don't realize
what it's like when you're making a
movie like this and you're showing um
you're getting intimate what is it
really like on set can you sort of
explain
what that is totally totally and you
should interview amanda she's great um
she's so so articulate so the the it
actually started even before hiring her
like when i when i initially reached out
to the actors i sent this like
director's book and as a part of it i
had this picture of salt and pepper and
it said let's talk about sex and it was
all about like hey i with this movie
just know there's sex in it there's
intimacy but i want to set like i really
really want to set a new gold standard
by which this is uh this is handled
but how it works how it works with the
intimacy coordinator is basically they
have conversations with the actors that
i'm not a part of
where the power dynamic that like could
potentially be perceived between a
director and an actor is completely
removed and they're able to talk about
like okay well what are you comfortable
with seeing what are you not comfortable
with seeing
why why would we show nudity in this
scene why would we not she sort of has
my input that i made in this like very
very detailed book of like sort of what
i was thinking about doing but not if
they didn't consent to it of course and
then amanda was able to then communicate
the specifics of
that meeting to each each of the
departments that would need to know that
information very discreetly
um i then work with the dp to figure out
the shot plan for for each of those
scenes given given what we know
and then on the day she's there to make
sure the set is closed to make sure that
all the expectations that have been set
are now being met
and to keep the actors stocked up with
breath mints
things that people don't think about
yeah
um yeah we'll talk again when it comes
to getting specific about the ending um
congrats on the movie thank you huge
[ __ ] for you um and you get to make the
thing that you just talked about yeah
thank you and i yeah i can't say enough
like i love your enthusiasm about movies
it really shows in your work so i'm
thank you for talking to me i say thank
you i'm happy to help you support this
one
awesome